what's going on guys this is rob and
we're we're in tuesday now so i mean
it's a good enough time to talk about
thor 4 right if you haven't seen the
movie by now it's because you don't want
to so the thing about this is we've had
these little discussions over the course
of different videos that we've done
right little moments where we've talked
about it for a few minutes here and
there about the idea of null in the mcu
and i figure like this is probably the
best time if there ever was one to talk
about the idea of null officially being
in the mcu because while marvel and sony
because technically because null is a
spider-man property sony does own the
rights to him technically speaking for
those of you guys who don't know there's
kind of an interesting thing here those
you guys don't know when marvel was
going broke in the 90s they sold off
movie rights and so it wasn't one of
those things where they had sold off the
film rights to spider-man and it was all
the characters we've created up to this
point it was
everything that's part of the spider-man
mythos basically meaning everything that
came after that presumably until disney
gets the rights back those movie rights
will be owned by sony so when miles
morales was created and introduced the
film rights for that are owned by sony
no the symbiote god who was introduced
in the last year or so maybe a couple
years that's owned by sony as well right
so anytime a new character is introduced
by marvel comics as part of the
spider-verse those film rights are
automatically owned by sony so i don't
know how many of you guys were familiar
with that or at least a little fuzzy
about it but that should clear things up
but while neither marvel studios or sony
have like directly told us that null is
coming to the mcu leaks rumors things
like that have all kind of put out this
information that like it's a project
they're working on in the background and
so i feel like this is the best time to
discuss this now one of the things that
i do want to bring up ryan over at
screen crush which by the way ryan i'm
100 serious man totally down for getting
lunch the next time i'm in new york
but he had a really cool video where he
was talking about the idea of the chaos
king and i do agree that would be a
compelling idea if i'm being honest
though if they were going to give us
something like that they would roll
those characters together because in the
comics they
more or less solidify that like chaos
king and null and those guys are all
just representations or like avatars of
oblivion so those of you guys who don't
know anything about comics oblivion is
really really powerful and it's this
huge fan debate that goes on just how
powerful oblivion is right is oblivion
actually the most powerful being in all
of existence and so on and so forth it's
just fan speculation don't let anybody
convince you it's an absolute truth it's
just something that fans believe to be
true but when it comes to this guy where
you have different cosmic entities out
there like eternity for example who
represents the the actual physical space
that the universe occupies right he's
the living embodiment of the universe so
if the universe could get up and walk
around it would be in the form of
eternity that infinity for example
represents the beginning of the universe
to its end right so the amount of time
that passes hence the name infinity
oblivion represents nothingness so when
a universe or even the multiverse is
destroyed and then it eventually comes
back that time in between when nothing
exists that's what oblivion represents
for characters like null and the chaos
king they represent oblivion in the same
way that like different things or people
represent like freedom right so like
freedom is not a tangible thing you
can't carry it with you you can exercise
it but you can't hold it in your hand
but someone like captain america quote
unquote represents freedom right just
different things along those lines right
being able to speak freely whatever it
is your opinion happens to be that
represents freedom so it's more like
concepts that illustrate this particular
thing as opposed to tangibly being that
thing that's how null and and the chaos
king work they cherish the idea of
nothingness right the the lack of life
different things like that now they're
not like thanos thanos is a nihilist he
believes life is meaningless so he
doesn't really value the lack of
existence it's one of those things where
he just loves the concept of death right
the death of everything is really what
he enjoys whereas someone like null or
the chaos king just simply enjoy the
idea of nothing existing at all and that
was the nature of null right the way
that null originally played out in the
in the comics right really was during
the king and black when you got like his
full-on origin up to that point he had
just appeared a few times and like you
knew he was coming and things were gonna
pop off when he showed up but the way it
worked is that in the beginning between
the end of the sixth universe and the
beginning of the second which is to say
the main marvel universe itself right
because the main marvel universe of
marvel comics has been destroyed and
recreated something like eight times as
it stands right now so between the end
of the sixth version of the universe and
the birth of the seventh null simply
just occupied the space in between he's
not really the offspring of oblivion in
the traditional sense again he was just
kind of a being born in the void and was
in effect the most powerful being in the
void at that point in time when the
celestials appeared and started creating
life around the universe that's when he
challenged the celestials he created the
all black and then killed a celestial
with it and then used the energies of
that celestial to imbue the sword even
further make it more powerful and went
to war against the rest of the
celestials ultimately he was defeated
and then cast away back into the void
where he effectively remained until he
was able to create symbiotes and then
once he created symbiotes instead of
going to war directly with the
celestials what he started doing was
conquering different things around the
universe and in fact destroying
different gods the idea being that in
doing so he could absorb the energy of
all the gods that he kills imbue himself
with more power and then destroy the
celestials ultimately he was defeated
right he was defeated by like a handful
of these gods out there and the
symbiotes that he had created turned
against him and then basically locked
him away inside the center of a world
that became planet symbiote that was
given to us and brian michael bendis's
guardians of the galaxy run well at
least planet symbiote was the idea of it
involving null didn't come until the
king in black but that's kind of how
things you know kind of a quick quick
and dirty two or three minute
explanation of his character but looking
at the movies all the pieces are there
right like all the pieces are in motion
for them to come along and just say yep
null is real and there's a couple
different reasons for that one of the
things to know is that in the comics
we're not explicitly told that null is a
multiversal being but it's basically
alluded to a really good example of this
is the nature of the symbiotes
themselves so not all symbiotes are
created equally for example in the
ultimate universe the symbiote was
actually created by scientists right
it's a genetically created organism
whereas in the main marvel universe it's
biological it's literally the living
abyss it was created by north so not
every symbiote across the multiverse can
directly be controlled by null but the
significance of this is that during the
king and black event spider gwen right
who most of you guys have heard of it
for no other reason than the events of
uh into the spider versus miles morales
that that version of gwen had gotten her
hands on the symbiont and when that
happened when she arrived in the main
marvel universe during the king and
black event null had actually subdued
her symbiote so he was able to control
it what this meant is that null can
control any symbiote across the
multiverse regardless of what universe
it comes from even though he originates
from the main marvel universe so that's
how we know that null is not necessarily
a multiversal being but can operate on a
multiversal level that is stupendously
important with our discussion here and
the reason for that is looking at the
pieces that are there when it came to
the sword right all black the necro
sword whatever you want to call it that
gore used in thor 4. that did not
originate with him right it was a weapon
that he found and started using and so
the very essence of that location
everything that we saw was very symbiote
like in nature so right off the bat that
points to no it doesn't give us a
definitive answer but it points to null
especially because it you know the
symbiote concept and null being the one
that created the symbiotes so then you
start looking at other little things
that have happened over the course of
the marvel cinematic universe for
example you have the celestial head that
was cut off you could argue that was
done by null but i think the single
biggest thing that illustrates the
existence of null is the fact that the
symbiotes themselves all share knowledge
across the multiverse and it's a very
easy detail to miss right so one of the
things to know and to really take this
into account is to look at the
post-credits scene of venom 2. if you
guys remember that post-credits scene
right you had eddie brock and you had
the venom symbiote who were in that
tropical place south america i don't
remember exactly where they were but
they were wherever it was that they were
at and then when the whole spell was
cast by doctor strange and it went
sideways because peter parker wouldn't
shut up and all that kind of stuff and
the events of loki impacted as well and
so on and so forth that the hotel room
and everything changed right and what
you saw was basically this information
dump from spider-man uh far from home
when j jonathan jameson had revealed
peter parker as being spider-man by way
of the broadcast or the video footage
from mysterio that the venom symbiote
looked at the tv and said that guy right
so like right off the bat the venom
symbiote knew who spider-man was now
spider-man does not exist in the
venomverse and in fact it's been
explicitly stated spider-man does not
exist in the venomverse that may change
but at the moment there's been nothing
to illustrate that he was there there's
been nothing to illustrate that the
venom symbiote knows who spider-man is
because he's not there and the venom
symbiote from the venom films originates
in that universe at least that seems to
be the case all the information that we
saw in venom one right they were just
out there in space and they were doing
their thing and you know all that kind
of stuff and they were ultimately
captured by the life foundation they all
seem to originate there so the question
that has to be asked here is how does
the venom symbiote know who spider-man
is or even know that spider-man is a
thing and the only way to draw that
conclusion is to say the symbiotes share
information on a multiversal level and
in fact this is stated by the symbiote
by venom in the post-credits scene for
venom too and that that that whole scene
that's why i say this is probably the
most the single most important
post-credits scene from phase four going
forward that no one paid attention to
that in that scene when you have eddie
brock and the venom symbiote talking
they're watching that telenovela which
honestly i kind of want to watch that
tell a novella to find out like what in
the world was going on because it seemed
pretty intriguing but there's that
comment that's made by the symbiote that
like everybody has a past and eddie
brock's response is wait so are you
telling me that like you know you're
hiding stuff from me and the symbiote
says 80 billion light years of hive
knowledge from across universes would
make your head explode right that
statement right there tells us that the
symbiotes share information across
universes who do we know out there who
was a venomous or had a venom symbiote
and knew the identity of peter parker as
spider-man the most obvious answer to
that is topher grace from the sam remy
spider-man films in spider-man 3. so
right off the bat we got we can really
draw this conclusion that you have
symbiotes across the multiverse topher
grace encountered tommy mcguire
spider-man and spider-man 3 knew his
identity that information was shared
with the entire venom hive mind so that
when the venom symbiote from the the
eddie brock films showed up into the mcu
it would recognize spider-man that's how
it knew and so having that kind of hive
mind knowledge the source of that is
null the symbiote god right nol is the
center of the hive he knows everything
they know now whether or not this like
solidifies the existence of null in the
mcu is really up for interpretation but
i don't see any reason why that wouldn't
be the case and in fact i would be
shocked if it wasn't i would be shocked
if after all these little tidbits of
things that we've seen right the necro
sword of gore the celestial head
floating out in space the post-credits
scene from venom 2 i would be shocked if
all this was given to us and it has
nothing to do with the entirety of null
at all now the other big question you
would have to ask is if null does exist
on a multiversal level how could no
possibly have any involvement in the
marvel cinematic universe whatsoever
because there's no symbiote there right
eddie brock and and venom and so on they
were yanked back to their own respective
reality well one of the things to
remember is that in that post-credits
scene for spider-man no way home a piece
of the venom symbiote was left behind
and so this in effect is a key and
anchor all it would take is for that
venom symbiote to bond itself to peter
parker or just any swinging dick in that
universe and suddenly knoll's got a way
in that's really all he needs that's all
he definitively needs to access any one
particular universe is for a symbiote to
be in that universe following that he
can dominate the will of that symbiote
control it and then presumably give
himself an n so that's how you end up
with null in the marvel cinematic
universe so that's my thought on this
right i mean it's one of the things
right i mean i know that like at this
point in time right this moment right
now july 12 2022 that we're recording
this video there's nothing definitively
out there to say we know for a fact null
exists in in the marvel cinematic
universe and in fact donnie cates the
writer of the king in black and the more
most recent venom run came out and said
no there's no references to null in
doctor strange too but he didn't say he
doesn't exist in the in the mcu or even
in the marvel cinematic universe
multiverse he just simply said there's
no references to him and doctor strange
too which we know now but having seen
that film so again i think it's entirely
possible that null exists out there on a
multiversal level no idea what's going
to come of it and no idea if we're
actually going to see it but i think if
we are and if marvel studios and sony
play their cards right the best way to
give us null in the marvel cinematic
universe is to build up to it right to
have him as this kind of villain that
appears maybe in some post-credit scenes
for like beyond the spider-verse or
whatever it is something out there where
it's like in that film and maybe other
multiversal spider-man films that we may
end up seeing later on down the line
before he's officially introduced that
like someone out there is basically
building like a symbiote army or is
bringing all these symbiotes under their
control and no one knows who it is and
then it's basically this big you know
venom revelation right this big king in
black revelation i don't know exactly
how that would unfold and honestly i
need to sit down and make a plan about
it but i think building up to null is
the best thing fingers crossed marvel
studios doesn't do what they always do
which is screw their villain up with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace